state your name for the record Wade
Barnes where were you born
Cincinnati Ohio Cincinnati Ohio how long
has the demon been plagued demon spirit
poltergeist whatever it was it all
started 2018 sometime late February and
it was almost exactly midnight Molly and
I were pulling into the driveway after
27 hours of being on airplanes and we
were just so excited to get home and as
we pulled in the driveway and the clock
struck 12:00 we noticed our front door
on the ground in front of the house
lying on the sidewalk water once the
bringer of life now the bringer of death
and the recipient of this cruel fate a
man by the name of George blade Barnes a
simple man simple dreams not a simple
fate for whether by his own volition or
by the cruel hand of fate a demon of
aquatic nature has entered into his home
and now we must tell a story but it's
very important for you to know that
every word of this story is true
this all happened and it all happened to
one very unlucky
individual this is the story of the
drown
[Music]
I'm so tired I first thought was we'll
deal with it tomorrow
so we went to sleep and just hope that
we were safe our best guess as to what
happened I mean we had a lot of thoughts
crossed our minds did someone try to
break into the house did the wood just
rot away but our biggest suspicion was
that it was a storm so I mean after the
front door we didn't get it fixed right
away we still don't fully have it fixed
but the rest of the year we had we had a
couple things crop up that week that
long as the summer progressed and a fall
the stopper in the sink didn't work we'd
have the toilet on the main floor fixed
we had to replace the kitchen faucet
because there was a drip under the
faucet the first to drip in the house
but it wouldn't be the last the water
heater went out we had to get that
replaced sediment started pouring into
the table upstairs just all kinds of
little things that just added up and add
it up and get it up and left us thinking
maybe maybe this was something more than
bad luck or typical house maintenance
with the amount of problems we've had
especially wet water leaking dripping
flowing flooding I don't know would you
say the sediment looked like
I don't know that I would say that no
you said that the tub flowed out pink
water was it because it was blood in the
water I think it was a bath bomb but you
know
I mean I can't rule it out paint me a
picture of everything starting from and
I quote well 15 5 a.m. when you finished
your DMV stream it was pretty typical
that we'd finish up between 1250 1:10
a.m. we'd wrap up right in that time
frame
12:55 we officially ended the stream and
normally we stay in the call and just
chitchat a bit to make sure we're all
gonna be there next week etc etc but as
soon as we ended the stream and I kind
of kicked back I heard a noise I didn't
know what it was so I told everyone in
the call to give me a moment and I stood
up and I took a step out of my office
and what I saw confused me the air vent
and the ceiling was dripping I didn't
think that was very normal it's like
okay is it because of the AC unit no now
this was January 31st and Cincinnati of
2019 this was the coldest night we had
had the entire year with wind chill
temperatures down the negative six so
why was there water in the air vent and
then past the air vent is a window that
window had water running down oh it must
be raining but the water's running on
the inside I walked over to it the wall
was popped out did it look a bit like a
vane something that would carry blood I
mean technically the way it was puffed
out yeah like if you're flexing a muscle
in your vein kind of sticks out it kind
of had that look to you check it for
no I didn't think to do that I ran up
the stairs and it was even scarier up
there we used to have a light fixture
that sat in front of our TV the light
fixture was pouring out water our
ceiling fan was spinning and was pouring
out water I can't say I stared at what
the fan was dripping out but if I had to
make a guess I would say it was probably
water our coffee table was covered in
water our floor was soaked in water and
then I remembered that Molly had told me
she was going to take a bath that night
and everything froze and my heart
dropped and the only thought I had was
that my wife had drowned
the tub was overflowing and I had to go
stop the tub and I had I was gonna have
to figure out how to deal with losing my
wife and I panicked I screamed her name
I I ran up those stairs faster than I
think I ever have or ever will again and
I ran into the bedroom and I looked in
the bathroom preparing myself for the
worst
[Music]
and thankfully she was standing there
with headphones in her ears she was
watching a live stream on her phone her
iPad but the tub was draining the shower
had pink water rising and then the panic
of thinking that something had happened
to Molly went away but then the panic of
trying to save our house began
this place I can feel it
something bad here didn't it especially
from this area here I'm getting the
sense that someone tried so hard and yet
everything fell apart around them does
this still have something to do with the
house and it goes yes but maybe I'm
getting ahead of myself
hello I'm mark that's me how did you get
in the door was open it was kind of on
the ground anyway good yeah okay I hear
you have a haunting I wouldn't say that
it's shut up is this where it started
yeah I was sitting right here whenever I
heard the noise and not being perfect
this chair has no lumbar support anyway
what did you hear
it sounded like plastic ruffling around
like maybe the cat was down here playing
with the plastic but wasn't Billy did
you investigate yeah yeah show me
reenact it relive it I'm sorry if it
pains you
okay.we more paints this air event just
had water flowing from it there's
plastic here the water was just dripping
onto the plastic and seeping into the
floor or the window there had water
pouring down the window at water you
know what has water inside of it you can
smell it now the light that's on there
we go feeling well chilly but it's the
middle of summer why would it be so
chilly so at this point we knew we had
to mitigate the damage we had to stop
whatever was happening the best we could
so we grabbed towels from the bathroom
we grabbed towels from the laundry room
we grabbed blankets we've got anything
we could find to help soak up water to
be stopped the tub from draining we
tried to soak up the water on the floor
in the bathroom we've tried to catch the
water pouring out the basement we tried
to dry off the window but it seemed like
no matter what we would do the water
would not stop
if I had a light on I'd be able to feel
a little bit better but you don't need
to see you need to feel we still have a
crack because they'd replace the drywall
down here so I think it's right above me
but I can't see it turn a light on all
right thank you
oh you didn't get it fixed by
professionals they do I sense more bad
drywall here more water more water okay
this was the other drywall ends up being
replaced show me
what this light on no turning off save
energy
look there's a light on in your office
you're just gonna leave it on I know
I'll turn it I'll turn it off no I got
it I thought I've got it your computer
zone that's it I was working right
before you but you know how much energy
people waste every year for no reason
why was this light on here when we came
down here so we could see to go back oh
that was so never mind
we're still on that the ceiling fan was
pouring the light fixture was pouring
and while the water was being caught I
was on the phone for two or three hours
trying to get somebody to help there was
nobody
the plumbers told me they could be there
than an hour hour and a half but it took
much longer and all the while we sat
there watching our lives washed and
drowned away
sealing in here basically yeah
there was water here
yeah that's why I was saying there was
water right here Rizzoli
yeah the fan and there used to be a
light fixture that set it right right
here
poured out water here all over the floor
went out water from the fan what happens
and water suddenly gushes it gets things
well what else
it destroys stuff that's not meant to be
what no are we done I need to talk to my
wife I'm thinking that your house is a
gateway for some greater evil to be born
through this world oh thank God I
thought your tummy my wife was pregnant
um we're even I mean I can't rule that
out
Grier evil also doesn't sound good
though that's like the second worst
thing you could have told me um the
worst thing would be a baby right now
answer the house cost a lot written war
I wanted to pay for climate change that
doesn't bother you I feel like we do pay
for that that is under attack
you don't need to keep paying this all
so soft
hey yo charge me anything for this are
you so you shut off the main water line
and water was still pouring yeah that
told me that
it sounds stupid but that told me that
either it was a drainage pipe or
something unexplainable was going on now
despite all the weirdness this seems
fairly normal that's what we thought too
we thought everything was normal and
this was just a horrible accident again
it was negative 6 degrees windchill
outside maybe one of the pipes burst
that was trying to drain the water from
the tub and the diff explained the water
coming back out through the shower the
next best thought we had and the plumber
that eventually showed up and not at 3
a.m. not at 4 a.m. not at 5 not at 6
but after 7 in the morning when the
plumber finally got there and the
ceiling fan did quit dripping but not
the light the light still poured when he
cut the holes in the ceiling in the
basement the holes in the walls and he
got into those pipes and he did his best
assessment what he could tell me was
your house is wet and we don't know why
so at the very least the only thing that
got resolved that night was the water
finally stopped pouring out of the
ceiling
but the plumber couldn't tell us what
happened so the next day after three
hours of sleep I got up and called
another plumber who came out after an
hour - and he found another place to cut
a hole in the wall in the basement took
one of those snakes with a camera on the
end and put it in the pipe went all the
way up to the t-junction that connects
the shower in the tub
all the way down from the pipe to the
sewage line and found nothing no sign of
it freezing no sign of it clogging no
sign of it being dirty this is where
they all the way up to check the
t-junction pipe or those two called
another plumber he came in put a snake
up the pipe put a snake down the pipe
all the way up to the way the shower and
the tub are all the way down to the
sewage in line pulled the thing back out
and basically looked at us and said no
sign of a clog no sign that it was
frozen
something went wrong but I don't know
what at that point I wasn't thinking of
what could possibly be humped in the
house I was just thinking of saving it
did you say
I don't know you would think that his
story would end there but no just
because people didn't know what the
problem was didn't mean that the problem
wouldn't continue not for mere weeks not
from mere months but nearly a year a
year of suffering at the cruel hand of
fate a watery demise to be buried in a
watery grave and so Wade suffered and he
suffered and he suffered and just when
he thought he could suffer no more faith
learn to be even more why don't you have
mercy on this poor man's soul lay faces
fate does not smile unless it is a cruel
smile and you may be asking yourself how
can I help this poor man in this
incredibly unbelievable and yet entirely
true story how can i alleviate some of
this suffering well you can't but what
you can do is immortalize the suffering
forever in this commemorative t-shirt
design showcasing his peak moment of
suffering right here so that you can
wear it upon your body and cherish the
deep delectable memories and in all
fairness all proceeds from this will not
go to me even though I probably deserve
it the proceeds will go to the man who
suffers so if you would like to support
mr. Wade Barnes in his moment of despair
why not consider buying this
commemorative t-shirt that's only
available for a limited amount
and in limited quantity at fast it may
already be washed away
[Music]